nicaragua's president starts a fourth
consecutive term after an election the
west called a sham critics say daniel
ortega is a dictator but his supporters
reject this so what's next for one of
the poorest nations in central america
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum to some daniel ortega is a
dictator who's ruthlessly crushed all
descent in nicaragua he won a fourth
straight term as president last november
after jailing opposition candidates and
banning international observers and
journalists from the country but his
supporters say he's standing up to
bullying from the west the u.s and eu
imposed new sanctions just before ortega
was sworn in again on monday most
countries stayed away from the ceremony
but ortega found support from russia
iran venezuela and china nicaragua
recently switched diplomatic ties from
taiwan to beijing
our latin america editor lucia newman
reports
this was daniel ortega's fourth
consecutive swearing-in ceremony flanked
by his wife rosalio murillo his vice
president he vowed to improve conditions
in nicaragua the second poorest country
in the americas after haiti
we are here again with a clean slate to
build peace to assure that nicaraguans
have a dignified life to eradicate
poverty in this country with sovereignty
and freedom
the presidents of cuba and venezuela
were there and also delegations from
iran bolivia russia and china
but ortega was snubbed by almost
everyone else
november's presidential elections have
been dismissed as illegitimate by much
of the international community the
majority of ortega's competitors were
imprisoned so they could not run and
thousands of others have gone into exile
and legitimacy is not an issue uh for
ortega he managed to essentially
consummate
uh his uh
his uh his plan uh to establish
a full
and classic
latin american dictatorship in nicaragua
hours before the ceremony the european
union and the united states announced
new sanctions against high-ranking
military and communications officials as
well as members of the ortega family
but exiled opponent monica baltodano a
former sandinista commander who once
fought alongside ortega questions their
effectiveness
they demonstrate that the international
community realizes what's happening in
nicaragua and that's why it imposes
sanctions they have a moral effect a
kind of consolation but in practical
terms they'll have little impact
while ortega celebrated his latest
inauguration
some 170 political prisoners languished
in what human rights advocates describe
as cruel and inhumane conditions
one of them is
my husband is losing his memory and is
in a deep depression after spending more
than a hundred days in a punishment
isolation cell
he can't remember the names or faces of
our daughters
ortega made no mention of his
pre-election promise to initiate a
dialogue with his political opponents
that may explain why most nicaraguans
whom al jazeera consulted about the
inauguration
preferred to say nothing at all lucia
newman al jazeera
daniel ortega is now in the 15th year of
his second stint in office it cements
his fourth term in a row despite him
leading an unpopular government
he came to power as a sandinista
guerrilla commander who helped overthrow
a dictatorship and became president in
1985. in 1990 he lost to violeta
chamorro but returned to power in 2007
and has been president ever since
he consolidated his control using force
to silence dissent while elevating his
wife and loyalists to high positions
poverty natural disasters and the
pandemic led to a mass exodus of people
from nicaragua to the border with the
united states over the past few years
ortega has been blamed for not doing
enough to strengthen the economy
all right let's bring in our guests in
the nicaraguan capital managua danny
shaw professor of latin american and
caribbean studies at city university of
new york
in sharjah jairo lugo ocando director of
executive education and graduate studies
at northwestern university in qatar and
in washington d.c michael shifter
president of inter-american dialogue a
warm welcome to you all and thanks so
much for joining the program today
michael let me start with you so hours
before nicaraguan president daniel
ortega was inaugurated the u.s and the
eu imposed sanctions on members of his
government who was targeted and how were
they targeted
well the the
this has been a continuation of a policy
of targeting
uh officials of the government
for
human rights violations uh as your setup
report indicated
there are political prisoners in in
nicaragua a substantial number
all the opposition candidates
for november's elections are in jail
and this is a highly repressive uh
autocratic
uh regime and so
those who have been responsible for
those human rights violations senior
officials in the government
um have been
sanctioned so that is
um the policy to try to uh apply
pressure
by the united states and by the european
european union uh against these
officials obviously there is a very very
serious human rights crisis uh in
nicaragua or the likes of which latin
america hasn't seen uh for many many
years and um and so that has been uh the
response whether that changes the
situation
at all uh on the ground remains to be
seen
but um certainly there is uh you know
there are those who are responsible for
this for this terrible situation and
they've been sanctioned
jairo as michael was just mentioning the
international community has issued
sanctions against ortega's government in
the past were those sanctions in the
past in any way effective and do you
think that these sanctions that were
issued
just before the inauguration will be
effective
well i i agree with the assessment that
of
of uh ortega being um you know somebody
who's
definitely
now in the realm of autocracy
and uh you know nobody who puts in
prison every single opponent that can
run against him in a national election
presidential election can be called a
democrat
and that's precisely what he does
however i would say that
ortega has a very different base uh
power base to that of other autocrats in
the regions like maduro in nicaragua or
canales in the castros in cuba
for once the economy in nicaragua has
not done as bad and for latin american
standards that's actually good and the
there has been a reduction in poverty we
can
debate
if it's true that is 50
of cuts in the past 10 years or not but
there has been some stability and now
i have been very skillful in developing
um interesting international um networks
for example he he
now closed a relationships with taiwan
and instead um china established a uh
embassy there but something recently and
of course that came with and lots of um
of uh of
aid and uh and commercial trade with
china which is now buying lots of the
nicaraguan products
as a discount but still
um
giving them a relief from the us and
european sanctions and the other base of
power that ortega has and we can't
forget this is that since the sandinist
revolution
the cortegas have never relinquished the
power in the army remember that even
when violeta de chamorro
won the elections in 1990
ortega's brother
stayed as the head of the armed forces
and that power of the sandinista of that
group of the same and all of the old
science above the rotators over the
armed forces has continued today he
governs in the same way that maduro was
in venezuela with a stronghold on the
army which is why i don't think the
sanctions are going to be that effective
uh danny you heard
jairo there talk about the alliances
between
president ortega and the venezuelan
president and the cuban president
the venezuelan president the cuban
president they were both there at the
inauguration to show their support china
russia iran they also sent delegations
there's a lot of talk right now about
international isolation but ortega still
has support as well correct
greetings from uh managua we don't live
in that same unipolar world of 1990 and
1991 with the collapse of the soviet
union nicaragua doesn't depend on the us
i think
u.s sanctions at this point in the
intensification of of sanctions are not
going to be as cruel as they've been in
the past against cuba against venezuela
because we now have this pluripolar
world we have china as a camp
russia as a diplomatic economic camp the
bolivarian countries we have things
shifting to the left across south
america in chile in honduras in peru
so i don't think that these blockades
one-fourth of the world's people wake up
every morning under u.s blockades these
blockades are not as effective as they
were for example in 1991 in cuba where
cuba was left with absolutely no other
trading partners
michael u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken has said that the u.s and its
partners will deploy diplomatic and
economic tools to support the
restoration of democracy and respect for
human rights in nicaragua so i want to
ask you i mean what else as far as
by the u.s can be done at this point and
what kind of pressure can be applied by
the u.s and by other countries to try to
make a
difference well first let me say that i
i think that is very very difficult
frankly um this is a regime as your
setup piece showed that's quite
entrenched i i agree with the analysis
that you know rely uh the armed forces
is a pillar of ortega's support i think
i don't think he's popular the polls the
relic the polls that i've seen shows
that he has about 20 25
of the nicaraguans who support him in
in venezuela maduro has about 12 13
um he has cemented ties with with
people's republic of china and broken
with taiwan he does
uh rely on russia but the fact of the
matter is that you know the the
situation is deteriorating you know 170
000 nicaraguans uh left in the last year
about 80 000 of those to the united
states that's unprecedented they're
going to costa rica so people are
fleeing the regime this there's a
widespread sense of fear and terror and
in that context this the the tools
available are not uh you know are not
are not great uh sanctions uh i don't
disagree with what's been said
that um it's unclear how effective
they're going to be i understand why
they're being they're being invoked and
applied but uh you know i'm certainly
not confident that's gonna that's gonna
make a change in ortega's uh
but i think there has to be more you
know i think international pressure is
important it's good
um but we know from experience that
international pressure
is
only
successful to the extent that there's an
internal
uh national
opposition force in nicaragua and today
that opposition force is largely in jail
the leaders are in jail
with no due process with no serious
charges with a just justice system
that's completely controlled by the
repressive regime and so first of all
there needs to be a regrouping uh of um
of some sort of uh opposition force
internally and um
the role that international that
external activists can play i think is
is limited but it can be helpful uh to
that end and so i think there needs to
be diplomatic i think more can be done
with the organization of american states
um there have been tough resolutions uh
but i think this could be more in
pressure internally and i'll just take
one other thing that i think is
important
that um you mentioned honduras honduras
will have a new government um
and that government i think is going to
be less supportive of ortega than the
previous government of guanoland or
juana linda hernandez and that may
affect
uh nicaragua's ability to get uh funds
and financing from the central american
bank if with with the change in
government honduras so there are
pressures i think from uh financial
institutions and diplomatically that can
make a difference but i agree it's
extremely extremely difficult jairo i
saw you nodding along some of what
michael was saying there when he was
talking about uh that from his
perspective there needs to be some sort
of regrouping when it comes to uh the
opposition in nicaragua so i want to ask
you if you think that's something that's
possible whether in the short term or
the long term
let me be very clear for those of us who
still defend the ortega's regime
or the cuban regime or the venezuelan
regime
if there was an open
and transparent election in any of these
countries the government would lose to
anybody in the position anybody
now having said that
altera is a different creature to maduro
and canales in castro in cuba
in the sense that he does have a segment
of support he you know as michael mike
was mentioning his his
support is a bit higher than other uh
autocrats in the region
um but having said that there's no
there's no
doubt
zero doubt it's a factual truth
that if there was an open and
transparent election ortega would lose
which is why he put in prison every
single one of the person who could
actually compete against him in the pre
in the past elections
and these functions is
sanctions per se has worked i mean
people always try to dismiss sanctions
let's let's not dismiss them let's
remember that sanctions were able
were the tools that enable us to get rid
of the parkade and uh system in south
africa and always is preferable to the
previous military interventions nobody
wants meditative nobody wants violence
in this case but there is the need for
the international community to act
speedy quickly to
encounter the agenda of
of ortega
the united states continue to be the
spiralist despite the sanctions despite
all this the united states continues to
be the main
provider of food of nicaragua nicaragua
was not self-sufficient the latest
report from the united states
agriculture department and
highlights the fact that there's a
record increase in food pushing from the
united states ukraine particularly grain
to nicaragua in this in the previous
year this is a fact so the united states
sanctions will have an effect on
nicaragua there's no doubt about that
and the question here is more the
european union the chinese the iranians
they're too far away they've highlighted
i'm sorry to interrupt let me get back
to you about that point that you're
making about the other sanctions as well
in just a moment because we are starting
to run out of time danny let me ask you
you know hiro was just saying there that
if elections had been held
properly that um
president ortega would have lost um i
want to ask you what your
viewpoint is on that how popular is
ortega in nicaragua right now
and are there credible achievements that
are being ignored by the international
community i feel like jairo and michael
have directly decontextualized recent
nicaraguan history and over a century of
nicaragua in history
the us has done everything to intervene
in nicaragua there was the 1980s contra
war one of the great crimes of the 20th
century 2018 was the u.s proxy war
it was an internationalized civil war
where bandits were terrorists with u.s
backing some
related to ngos that had a at least on
the surface
an innocent appearance they attacked and
burned sandinista universities and
sandinista homes
so nicaragua has been under great duress
it's nikai was right to protect itself
through its armed forces through the
police
against these would-be coup mongers they
resisted a coup in 2018
and nicaragua continues to develop
women's projects peasant projects and
i've been traveling to nicaragua since
2005.
and i see something completely different
than what haida and michael have
described
uh jairo i saw you uh reacting uh to um
what was being said there uh please go
ahead
it's basically saying that every single
candidate of the position is a cia agent
or something and this is the traditional
thing that that people say about this
regime that everybody is a member of the
sea that everything is a conspiracy and
i'm absolutely aware of the history you
know since walker invaded nicaragua in
the 19th century you want to talk about
invasions about u.s intervention nobody
wants a u.s intervention but the truth
is not all these candidates are members
of the cia or plotting against them
there was many of them were legitimate
even left-wing even left-wing candidates
and they were all imprisoned how can you
explain that
are you saying that all of them are cia
agents all of them are part of a
conspiracy
an individual like dora maria tellez was
a terrorist and she bombed buildings and
she had trucks of armed bandits the u.s
would put those individuals in jail or
maybe they wouldn't because we have the
case of january 6th but no people is
allowed to lead a violent coup against a
democratically elected government as we
saw in 2018 but they resisted that proxy
war
michael let me ask you um at his
inauguration president ortega announced
that nicaragua and china had just signed
a series of strategic agreements uh that
would include officially incorporating
nicaragua into beijing's global belt and
road initiative
as well as other trade programs
how much do you think that's going to
help nicaragua and how much does that
concern the united states
well look the united states obviously
there are global tensions with china and
i think uh china's
increasing influence and expansion in
all of latin america is something that's
certainly high on the agenda a political
policy agenda in the united states and
the united states
has to be
you know competitive with china and has
to make a better offer than than china i
just think that um the prospects for
economic development uh are not great no
matter who is involved in in nicaragua
given that incredible deterioration in
the country if people are leaving in
droves
and it's turned into a complete police
state
um this is not these are not great
conditions for investment and economic
prosperity um these are conditions for a
country that's going to continue to
decline economically socially what
people that want to leave economic
opportunities and the like i think the
significance of the china shift is more
geopolitical
and
you know there could be major projects
that that china provides in in nicaragua
like it's done in other countries but
this is no substitute for economic
development and if you're interested in
social economic development and the the
improvement of people's uh living
standards um this is not a formula to do
it this is a police state it's support
it's turned into to a pariah you may
defend it uh but it's you know on
principle and the dignity of the
nicaraguans but the fact is they're the
humanitarian uh conditions there are
very dire and are only likely to get
worse no matter what happens so i think
one has to focus on that on the
nicaraguan people and they wouldn't be
leaving in droves like they are today if
they weren't for the economic problems
and the political repression and people
just being very very frightened
danny it looked to me like you were
reacting to what michael was saying
there when he was talking about the
worsening humanitarian and economic
crises going on in nicaragua go ahead
well whenever we talk about the subject
of migration we have to put it in its
proper context which is centuries of
colonialism and neocolonialism and the
reality that the money
in the north is worth more than the
money here across central america in
latin america but i see in nicaragua
very different than the daya tribes or
the constant vilification that we hear
from the new york times the wall street
journal the cnn and fox i see a
nicaraguan people who continue to build
an alternative system an anti-capitalist
system i see uh nicaragua fortified
every day
by these new relationships with vietnam
china russia no longer can the u.s
control the world and realize it's
unipolar hegemonic dreams because
of this constant growing unity among the
blockaded states so we see iran trading
with venezuela venezuela finding russia
russia finding nicaraguan on and on uh
jairo um let me ask you we've talked in
this program about uh the countries that
have taken a stance against president
ortega we've talked about the countries
uh that are supporting him right now are
there other countries that are trying to
make diplomatic inroads with ortega uh
and trying to sway him in that way
through diplomacy
yeah the the big player here in the
planet
the person who can actually have an
impact
uh obrador has been an allied and you
know open ally of um of ortega in many
ways although they just had a rift of
about if he was going to go for the
inauguration or not but at the end
will have a very important role to play
in trying to
bring ortega back to the table of
negotiations i just want to make two
additional points for what i've been
discussing here first of all the the
role of china now paradoxically china
could be detrimental to
nicaragua because the biggest nicaraguan
project is a second canal the canal of
nicaragua which you will unify the
pacific and atlantic through nicaragua
and the people who are less interested
in that project are the chinese because
they already control the uh
cairo
i'm i'm very sorry we have run out of
time so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there but thanks so much to
all of our guests danny shaw hiro lugo
ocondo and michael shifter
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim jroom the whole team here
bye for now
[Music]